alors eduardo arroyo en 1963 une
exposition en espagne qui déplaît au
pouvoir franquiste
à l'époque était obligé de choisir
l'exil parce que finalement il y en a
certains artistes étaient acceptés comme
ta pièce comme heroes mais toi tu as été
obligé de temps avec moi
[Applaudissements]
oui mais c'était à moi seul de la partie
avant je suis parti à 58 et puis
effectivement après cette exposition qui
est retourné en trois jeux plus rien
fait en espagne jusqu'à que j'ai
récupéré mon passeport
en fait je voulais être écrivain au
départ non oui oui
en face des contradictions basque aussi
et sexy les pour être clément s'est
imposé une ambiguïté contraction très
grande mais enfin je dessinais beaucoup
enfants et enseignants la peinture
supprime le problème de la langue c'est
être l'ex il quitte à forcer à pain
certaine manière en tout cas cet
éloignement de l'espagne et de la langue
d'espagne on m'a fait peut-être donné
quand tu fais une peinture en coteaux
biographique un peu politique pas
militante mais politique post et
tableaux racontent des histoires qui
vont les histoires sur les membres
seulement c'est à dire que tout le monde
à part on a parlé facilement de peinture
politique mais moi si ce pari de quoi ça
se mange de tout ça simplement tu vas
voir pas uniquement une obsession il a
des gens qui sont cédés par les fleurs
ou par les champignons ne peut parler en
commission par le co produit et moi
c'était l'espagne et qui effectivement
aujourd'hui ça semble un peu rhétorique
parler ce que ça a donné plusieurs
allemands l'espagne est devenue un pays
comme les autres
alors donc aujourd'hui tout un peu
difficile de l'imaginer qu'est ce que
c'était c'est ce qu'on appelle la
figuration narrative qui acceptent cette
étiquette
c'est à dire que j'accepte parce que bon
c'est est venu
non et la critique en général donc de
loin des mouvements ou à des générations
peut-être c'est plus facile aussi pour
se comprendre mais enfin moi je me
considère un peintre très indépendant
toujours je pars quand je dirais que
j'appartiens à une génération de
peintres qui ont lutté au
début des années 60 contre la station
qui les actions lyrique un truc contre
du chant c'était très très fort très
scandaleux et à l'époque c'est vrai que
des gens comme jean françois revel ou
mandiargues ont protesté quand je vais
faire virer quelqu'un tu y ailles ou une
wii j'ai laissé réduit tableau qui
s'appelait la fin tragique de marcel
duchamp
c'est à dire que ça produit en un grand
tollé c'était la dernière manifeste qui
a signé vrai ton et ses amis avant de
mourir c'était il ya eu de manifester
aujourd'hui ceineray incompréhensible je
voudrais qu'on principe qu'un groupe de
peintres ou de manifeste qu'il a mal gré
de votre peintre est aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas imaginer
et pourquoi tu es anti dali parce que
thalys étaient assez figuratif quand
même dans les secours d'urgence et il
faut le dire tout de suite c'est vrai
que c'est pas très élégant de parler des
morts et ça c'est une chose que j'ai à
dire qu'ils étaient vivants tout est de
savoir exactement mais enfin lui c'était
vraiment j'étais venu c'était ce terrien
tesero tout simplement comment mais
qu'on le fasse parce qu'il est et
monarchistes aussi amenons emballe tout
c'est pas parce qu'ils étaient moins si
c'était parce que quelqu'un qui avait
quand même dit devant le camp de franco
a tué cinq jeunes gens en 1975 il a dit
il faut les tuer tous comme des rats et
il n'arrive même pas un mot de pitié lui
qui était quand même un catholique
fervent pour des gens qu'au fond ils
étaient des jeunes de jeunes gens qui
étaient quand même
par terre trop des balles tu penses quoi
de l'espagne actuelle je dirais que le
retour des bourbons
pays démocratique tu pensais que ça
allait se passer comme ça du tout parce
que moi ça coûte toujours je me suis
trompé ce à quoi je pensais en politique
ne s'est pas avéré ce que je pensais non
j'ai su je pense que nous sommes un pays
comme les autres je répète c'est les
choses qui étaient là j'ai lutté contre
cette idée d espagne est différente
nous vivons une situation qui me
convient tout à fait je pense que
enfin je crois
que
curieusement si vous voulez des gens
comme moi qui sont des gens
traditionnellement des gauches sont très
très contente
lara balle aussi une sorte de carillo
aussi oui c'est ça qu'il avait de gens
ils ont les gens de patients qui sont
gré qui soutiennent par exemple
le travail de droit qui me semble très
très intelligente et très très bien tu
serais qui s'ils n'étaient pas arroyo
toujours être quel peintre les gars ça
je vous des mélanges de peut-être
quilico picabia
c'est un peu de terrain et
et aussi quelques gouttes des légers
mais qu'en même temps pour faire un
tableau ça dépend ça peut venir dans
quatre cinq jours ça peut durer un mois
ça dépend de mélange ça vaut combien ça
vaut couper et parlons d'argent
moi j'aurais et compte parler argent mes
concerts
combien bon prison de 600 me font à
halime francs tu publies un bouquin chez
plon dans la collection carnets qui
s'appelle sardines à l'huile bouillante
c'est là c'est la moindre des choses le
travail de quoi bon ma vie ma vie mes
passions mais
les humeurs sida y avoir une définition
du toit d'un dictionnaire
ahoyo deux mois moi je dirais que
passions surtout patient jeudi être
peintre c'est le 2 murray pourrait
absolument oui oui il faut pas qu'il
faut rester parce que être peintes 7
quelque chose de
de concret n'en est pas une blague un
peu
enfin
il faut pas non plus penser à
à cette l'idée de la peinture comme les
aspirations pour dénoncer l'idée de que
tu veux peindre et pu voir le demeurer
jusqu'à la fin et que le grand enjeu
c'est savoir points pour moi
si je suis capable encore fait un
tableau la vie si tu avais déjà adhéré
mais l'idée c'est ça l'idée c'est est ce
que je suis capable encore de tableau
aujourd'hui un homme serein après je
suis un homme doublement tranquille et
surtout plus tôt je virais classique et
même des gens même qui m'aiment beaucoup
il prendrait pour nos vis-à-vis avec un
avis un brin réactionnaire de ça avant
oui ça y est formidable
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux